today we're gonna discuss the most
popular class 1c student in the history
of mankind and one of the few characters
to have their own Funko pop hit
Ossetians oh we're gonna explain
everything from his new costume upgrades
to what his future quark awakening look
like and we'll also delve into why one
tea tree way thinks that Shinzo could be
his successor but before we begin this
video will cover some information
regarding scenes of development that
hasn't yet been seen in the anime but
I'll keep plot spoilers to a minimum
that being said if you really want to
avoid any and all spoilers then just hop
on my channel and check out some of my
spoiler free videos ok let's get into it
since the sports festival shinzo has
added two new support items to his
arsenal one of which is just insanely
overpowered but in order to explain them
let's first remind ourselves what his
quirk is in the first place and what its
limitations are so shines' quirk is
called brainwashing and it grants him
the ability to control someone to an
extent if they verbally respond to him
but as we've seen the brainwashed person
can break out of jinzo's control if they
receive sufficient physical contact such
as a nice slap to the head or if the
spirits of previous quark users
seemingly cause you to break your
fingers though I think that last one was
probably exclusive to Deku in the manga
shinzo explained a few things about his
quirk that we didn't already know for
example he's never tried brainwashing
two people simultaneously as he believes
that it would split his focus too much
though considering he's never even
attempted it that might just be him
under estimating himself additionally
his control of a person is limited in
the sense that he can't make someone
draw on their own knowledge so for
example if he asked a person to write
down the best arc in my hero academia
they wouldn't be able to do it because
that would require them to think and
then draw on their own pre-existing
knowledge whereas if he held up a copy
of the overall arc and just asked them -
I don't know write the letters on the
front page they would be able to do that
because it's just a basic task that
doesn't require any real brain power
it's also worth noting that he can't
command people to speak either but
anyway let's move on to why you probably
clicked on this video what does that
mask on his face actually do contrary to
what you might initially think this
masters not projections as voice or make
it louder in any way no my friends
jinzo's persona caused modify the sound
of his actual voice and allow him to
mimic the voice of other people and
pretend to be them like he says in this
panel the place in the mask move around
and alter the sound of his
voice coming out of that little box
thing at the front let's see how this
works in practice in the class 1a versus
cost 1b arc we can see closed a from
class won't be talking in this panel
then we see shinzo flicked the white
panel on the side of his mask and
suddenly he's talking with co Said's
voice and he even gets this beast guy to
respond to him and succumb to his
brainwashing in a real-life situation
even if there are villains who know what
his quote can do if he has the ability
to copy the voice of anyone who speaks
then that enables him to do two things
either he can use it to brainwash them
by surprise or his mere presence will
stop the villains from communicating
with each other out of fear of being
brainwashed whichever way you cut it
that's an extremely useful thing to have
and exactly what shinzo needs now moving
on to his second support item that my
friends is Isaiah's famous binding cloth
in the sports festival we saw that a
race head described shines' quirk as
crazy powerful and he said the fact that
Shinzo couldn't make it onto the hero
course was an example of how the
entrance exam was flawed and given that
hey Toshi is actively trying to transfer
onto the hero course it makes sense that
Isiah would kind of step in and teach
him a few tricks
now the binding cloth took Aizawa five
years to master and he taught himself
from scratch this means that Shinzo
actually does have a slight advantage
over the young array said given that he
himself actually has a teacher in Izawa
and this was exemplified in the joint
training arc will because he stands out
competently using the cloth to both
fight and maneuver himself around check
him out in his panel he is literally
swinging like spider-man he also uses
the binding cloth to pull down a metal
pipe on top of this guy however it
should be noted that this move wasn't
strong enough to take down most villains
but regardless we still see that Shinzo
has pretty good aim at the binding cloth
and can accurately shoot it at enemies
even if they're pretty far away and he's
capable of yanking them towards him
albeit not entirely towards him just
give him a few more gym sessions and I'm
sure he'll be able to now moving on to
why Aizawa is seemingly training Shinzo
to join the hero course it's clear that
he sees a lot of himself in Hitoshi
which was evidenced by this panel in the
manga when I shall refer to them as the
same type of person that being someone
who was a powerful quark that isn't
really oriented to combat Shinzo
obviously has great potential but lacks
a lot of strength beyond his quirk and
so as I was kind of taking it upon
himself to train him in much the same
way that all my is doing
midoriya it's clear that shinza wants to
be a hero who helps people
but unlike deku and back ago Jinzo isn't
saying that he wants to be the number
one hero or the best hero he's just a
guy that wants to save lives so in that
vein it would make sense if he followed
every says path and became sort of like
an underground hero who shines away from
the spotlight fewer villains would know
about his quirk meaning he'd be able to
catch more of them by surprise
also just to reiterate Izawa is a
fantastic teacher so within a year or
two I reckon shinzo will likely learn to
master the binding cloth and on the
basis that shinzo will eventually join
the hero course he'll be able to try out
these new techniques when his course is
getting attacked by villains every other
month well that's if they put him in
class 1-a anyway and with that explained
let's move on to what a potential quirk
awakening would look like for shinzo
from my point of view quirk awakenings
either do one of two things
they either allow you to surpass the
defined rules and limitations of your
quirk all they add something new that
you didn't even think about in shines'
case I reckon an awakening will consist
of one or all of these things firstly
his brainwashing wouldn't be able to be
broken by physical contact
right now a light bump is probably
enough to escape his trance so an
awakened version of shinzo squawk would
mean that no matter what happens a
person remains under his control and the
only way they can break out of his
control is if he wants that to be so
secondly his quirk could activate
without people needing to respond to him
this would make him so overpowered what
if he could just bring what someone who
simply heard his voice and all he needed
to do was say a specific phrase with
that type of power he could be one of
the best heroes in the world just
imagine if all one was going crazy at
camino and instead of all might needing
to use a hundred percent of his
remaining power all you needed was
Shinzo to pull up and say a certain
phrase and all for one stops dead in his
tracks I don't know about you but I
think that would be a lot more effective
than getting into a fistfight with the
guy thirdly what if Shinzo was able to
control multiple people simultaneously
this would allow him to take out entire
groups of villains in one go imagine
shinza was placed in a situation like
the attack on the usj that was basically
a small army that came to attack them
but if Shinda was there and able to
control multiple people at the same time
he could have taken out quite a few
villains there and then and generally I
think it plays into the notion that
shinzo himself is pretty useful for
dismantling entirety
two bad guys by himself which is still
the case whether his quirk is awakened
or not because with the persona cause he
can pretend to be anyone he wants but
anyway the fourth thing that I believe
would constitute an awakening for shinzo
work is that when he's brainwashing
people he should be able to get them to
draw on their own knowledge this would
be next level brainwashing right now he
can make people perform pretty basic
tasks but if he could make them draw on
their own knowledge imagine the
possibilities this could be used in
quite a similar way to shin emoto's
confession quirk and if you want to know
more about that quirk then check out my
she has like I explained a video but
yeah I think if we can make people draw
on their own knowledge then not only can
you find out people's secrets but you
can also extract information and then
use that to take down criminal
organizations and finally the last thing
that I believe shins as awaken quark
could include is the ability to project
his voice microphones don't really work
on Shindler's quark because they distort
his voice too much but what if Shinzo
found a way to exponentially increase
the sound of his voice and reach a large
crowd of people what I'm saying is that
imagine his voice was so loud that he
could speak to an entire stadium of
people and then imagine if they didn't
even need to respond to him for him to
brainwash them jinzo's quark basically
lays the groundwork for something like
this to be possible maybe I'm
over-exaggerating by saying a whole
stadium but still I imagine a large
crowd if Shinzo awakened his quark
I reckon something like this would
definitely be possible but what do you
guys think is there something else that
shinza would be able to do if he
awakened his quark and let me know in
the comments what you think of the
persona cords and the binding cloth if
you had to pick only one what would it
be for me personally I'd recommend that
shinzo stick with the mask simply
because it's more tailored to his quark
but that being said the binding cloth
does give him some options that would be
better in a 1v1 situation like if you
were in the sports festival and you saw
R Shinzo pulling up with that mask on
you'd know not to say anything around
the guy whereas if it was a 1v1 battle
and he had only the binding cloth that
would kind of make it a different
ballgame but that's everything from me
today guys be sure to subscribe to the
channel as I'm trying to reach my
ultimate goal of a thousand subscribers
and check out my video explaining
Kirishima is unbreakable form if you
like this video and you hadn't seen that
one already then I reckon you probably
liked it see you next time peace